en principio en qué consisten estas
interrupciones que están afectando las
cadenas de suministro qué productos se
han visto afectados pero la gran mayoría
recuerde que el mundo entero tiene un
flujo de productos que va desde china
hasta europa pasando por los eeuu todo
es un flujo continuo de productos lo que
está sucediendo es que hay un bloqueo si
hay un faltante muy grande de
contenedores todos los productos se
mueve por contenedores déjame darte la
cinta estadística el 90% el 90% de todo
lo que se mueve en el mundo se mueve a
través de barcos por mar entonces cuando
tienes estas trabas estos cuellos de
botella tan grandes y la falta de
contenedores pues definitivamente hay
una ruptura en la cadena abastecimiento
que es lo que está generando este
problema bueno uno de los países que se
ha declarado golpeado es estados unidos
y el presidente joe biden ayer anunció
que mantendrá abiertos los principales
puertos del país durante 24 horas los 7
días de la semana este tipo de medidas
realmente sirven para combatir la
situación sin lugar a dudas sin lugar a
dudas son medidas 7 que al meterse a la
casa blanca en este en este proceso
están reconociendo la gravedad la
seriedad
si nosotros tenemos una interrupción
prolongada en los flujos de producto
pues definitivamente la economía se ve
afectada se ve afectada porque la gente
que necesita seguir comprando y
vendiendo para que la economía se siga
moviendo lo que ha generado que los
puertos al haber esta interrupción pues
lo que necesitan es aumentar el número
de horas que se trabajan estos puertos
para el movimiento de los contenedores
no solamente es lo que sucede en el
puerto sino piensa que en el puerto
pasan los productos a los camiones y así
sigue el movimiento pero si los silos
contenedores están trabadas trabados en
los puertos o los barcos están trabados
esperando para ser descargados tiene
nuestro problema bueno los expertos
están explicando que se podría generar
una crisis en los próximos meses ante la
falta de productos o de materias primas
que al mismo tiempo llevan a esta base
desabastecimientos ya que suban los
precios con qué otras medidas se puede
combatir este panorama pero no hay duda
de que habrá una subida de precio creo
que tuvo un proceso lento esto es un
proceso en el cual no se puede
reaccionar rápidamente piensa el tiempo
que demora cuánto demora un contenedor
de llegar de china a los eeuu estás
hablando de tres semanas entonces si
tienes eso exagerado o ampliado esta
cantidad de problemas es mucho más
difícil entonces la única manera en este
momento es tener paciencia creo que lo
que están haciendo los puertos
norteamericanos de aumentar el número de
horas que estás trabajando es una medida
muy importante para poder aliviar de
alguna manera el problema pero sin
embargo no hay nada que hacer lo que sí
están haciendo que la gente está
tratando de ser más proactivas tratar de
generar en vez de tener esos picos de
venta tan tan acentuado que se generan
en diciembre sino hasta qué punto
podemos mejorar pues atenuar esa venta y
muchas de las empresas están tratando de
convencer a los consumidores que
empiecen a comprar desde ahora bueno
señores después a usted muchísimas
gracias por este análisis por
compartirlo con nosotros en france 24